will they given the performance of the
company you know since the company when
public sales have definitely slowed but
you know Kip Tindell says that you know
the wages are part of a whole business
model that he has which is he hires very
educated people he gives them a lot of
training he pays them well and then
ultimately he expects them to be more
productive then lower paid workers will
be so I think what investors are asking
is like but we haven't seen it right so
what what's been happening and you know
what he says is that you know his
business and he's been running The
Container Store for more than three
decades it's only been public for a year
and a couple months but you know he said
our business doesn't go like this you
know it goes like this
and there's down cycles and really
unfortunate for him and investors that
human public just says right out I
started yeah and right and so investors
are frustrated and they're trying to
focus on on any issue that they think is
going to help the bottom line so would
it help the bottom line I guess directly
if he pulled back on this wage you know
I think the argument is that possibly in
the short term but not in the long term
and you know what a lot of these
companies that pay well such as Costco
you know you can make an argument for a
lot of different companies but they all
say that you need to look about you need
to look in the long term and we're going
to have bad quarters like every company
does but we don't want to make decisions
based on those bad quarters we want to
be able to keep our eyes and what we
think is still most important we want
investors who can kind of think the way
we think right well and did he give any
indication then if he's not going to
move on wages what he might move on to
get the company yeah back on track so
they have a couple of initiatives that
are underway now and they should be in
all the stores by the end of the year
and the first is a service where they
send an organizer or into your home and
organize everything for you that's
called contain home and then the bigger
initiative is a premium closet called
TCS closets it's a it's a kind of you
know walk-in closet would it could sell
for
you know several thousand dollars which
is would do a lot for them yeah and you
know he's hoping that that will boost
sales for say the next three years and
then he says after that we have to think
of something else okay does he regret
taking the company public at all I don't
think he likes so much scrutiny but I
think he also leaves it was the right
choice for the company okay because now
you're a public company CEO right and
you're going to get a lot of a lot of
heat for the